good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe rogan may be the
most popular broadcaster in the
english-speaking world right now every
episode of his podcast called the joe
rogan experiences reaches about 11
million people and some of the episodes
get an audience many times that how many
people is that it's a lot for
perspective last night cnn's highest
rated show had a little over 700 000
viewers
total
so joe rogan is big and unlike cnn he's
not especially political his show covers
pretty much everything comedy science
nutrition the paranormal recreational
drug use exercise mixed martial arts
music hollywood and a huge range of
other topics often with guests you've
never heard of
rogan is not a reactionary unlike most
people in the media he doesn't think he
already knows everything he's genuinely
curious and so he lets his guests speak
his longest interview lasted for more
than five hours it was with the stand-up
comedian
when rogan does talk about politics it's
pretty clear he's not an ideologue he
interviews everybody liberals and
conservatives as well as a lot of people
like mike tyson who could be either one
and he does it most of the time with
respect and self-deprecation he's not an
expert on politics he's not pretending
to be one rogan just asked questions and
he notes the obvious
it's this last quality that makes the
people in charge hate and fear joe rogan
if you're trying to sell an absurd
obviously untrue idea it is possible
that joe rogan's going to call you on it
not because he's a partisan he's not but
because he just can't help but notice
that's his secret
a few months ago rogan watched the white
house press secretary lie about the
fda's approval process for pfizer's
covet vaccine so he said something about
it watch jen sake's talking about
misinformation online and combating
misinformation
she distributed misinformation of course
because she said that it's approved by
the fda in their gold standard
yeah what he said was true roger's
pretty literal actually it's one of the
reasons people trust him and he was
right in this case gensake was lying to
the country and it wasn't even an
especially clever lie anyone with
internet access could have verified that
what jensaki said was a total crook from
the podium too
but when joe rogan points this out it
really stings a lot of the people
listening to him believe him and the
white house took notice
so what happened next
well here's jen saki from yesterday
calling on joe rogan's employer to
censor him watch
this disclaimer it's a positive step but
we want every platform to continue doing
more to call out misinformants and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information but ultimately you
know our view is it's a it's a it's a
good step it's a positive step but
there's more that can be done
there's more that can be done hey you
little fascist that's a threat
it's exactly what it is politicians and
their spokes chicks didn't used to talk
this way they were not allowed to talk
this way because the first amendment
explicitly prohibits it
you're not allowed to use government
power to shut down broadcasters who
criticize you
period
and now that's exactly what they're
trying to do
so far joe rogan's employer spotify
hasn't caved to the pressure rogan still
has a job but the company is bending
it's deleted more than 20 000 covid
related podcast episodes made by other
spotify hosts spotify claims they quote
cause harm
how exactly can a podcast cause harm
spotify didn't explain because of course
they couldn't explain podcasts don't
cause harm weapons cause harm
anyone knows anything about american
business right now understood what's
actually going on in a moment like this
it is virtually impossible to run a
public company no matter how hard you
try it's not just in podcasting it's not
just spotify it's any company with
shareholders from breakfast cereal
manufacturers to tennis shoe retailers
the political pressure is coming at
these companies from all sides from
activist investors from the media from
their own employees
every day is a brand new crisis imagine
the emails between the ceo and the pr
department they never stop and under
those circumstances it's impossible to
think clearly to stand on principle or
even to consider your own best interest
long term
that's what's going on with spotify they
probably don't want to censor anybody
they're being pushed to in their case
pressure to censor joe rogan over his
views is coming from other content
providers on the site and most of them
are d-listers you should know
the other day that annoying fake duchess
from la and her brain-dead husband
threatened to walk if spotify refused to
muzzle joe rogan quote hundreds of
millions of people were affected by the
serious harms of rampant miss and
disinformation every day they yelped
through a publicist
but of course they don't mean it they're
not going anywhere
these two grifters have a 25 million
dollar podcast deal with spotify for
essentially no work
so far we believe they produced just
over 30 minutes of content
that means these two been paid about a
million dollars for each minute of
talking they've done
that's a good gig it's too good to leave
but their performance does raise the
question
what exactly about joe rogan's podcast
has caused quote serious
harm we're literal too so we scoured his
archives to find out
and it turns out as usual the opposite
is true joe rugged is actually a force
for safety in this world
watch this clip in which he warns the
public about the dangers of approaching
gorillas in the wild it turns out
sneaking up on a gorilla as joe rogan
pointed out could lead to actual serious
harm
we're so soft we think it's okay to look
at a wild animal in its eyes that's how
stupid we are hi
cool we're cool man we're from national
geographic society we just come to make
sure your baby's okay
crazy 800 pounds silverback he's
crawling through the trees
it's right in your face he's got fangs
and he only needs vegetables and
shredded only designed you up oh and you
can't even imagine what an 800 pound
gorilla strength is like because you
would think of it like an 800 pound man
but it would really be more like a 3000
pound
he's interested in animals by the way
again he's curious that that's part of
the allure people in the media are paid
to be curious to ask questions to wonder
about other people none of them do they
just want to lecture you
this guy actually is interested
but no one is criticizing him seems to
know that doesn't seem like they've
actually listened to his show neil young
probably never has neil young is an
elderly folk singer from the nation of
canada young has already pulled his
music from spotify in protest of rogan's
open-mindedness does neil young actually
own his own music we don't know but we
know that the gesture received
widespread applause from the usual
morons who then revealed to themselves
to be even dumber than you thought they
were variety magazine for example which
still exists informed us that neil young
stands against joe rogan makes him quote
a hero to the younger generations
right
because if there's one person kids of
today revere worship like a god it's 76
year old neil young they take neil young
over joe rogan any day because young
people everywhere are anxious to side
with the biden administration and demand
the firing of any podcaster who
interviews people kamala harris
disagrees with
it's hilarious
they're more out of touch than neil
young is
but at cnn they've convinced himself
it's all totally true because joe rogan
is peddling misinformation therefore he
must be stopped
you think about major newsrooms like cnn
that have health departments and deaths
and operations that work hard on
verified information october 19. and
then you have talk show stars like joe
rogan who just wing it who make it up as
they go along and because figures like
rogan are trusted by people that don't
trust real news rooms we have attention
a problem that's much bigger than
spotify much bigger than any single
platform
people are trusting joe rogan over
eunuchs can you imagine
damn the people
they should be watching cnn cnn has
departments and desks and entire
operations designed to verify
information and filter out
misinformation
and that's why they described ivermectin
which in joe rogan's case was prescribed
by a human doctor is quote horse
dewormer and did it on like nine
different shows
and those same standards led them to
suggest famously that a passenger jet
must have been sucked into a black hole
whether it was hijacking or terrorism or
mechanical failure or pilot error but
what if it was something fully that we
don't really understand a lot of people
have been asking about that about black
holes and on and on and on they're also
referencing the twilight zone which is a
very similar plot that's what people are
saying i know it's preposterous but is
it preposterous do you think
we can't get enough yes that clip was
from eight years ago but we watch it
every single morning along with our
pilates and sauna just to get ready for
the day
and if you want to watch a lot more like
that cnn has just announced you can
subscribe to cnn plus and don lemon will
be on there constantly for a small extra
fee
so that's their answer to joe rogan more
nonsense but the lowest rated dummies in
the entire tv business
joe rogan meanwhile consistently turns
out interesting informative programming
just by being curious just by asking
obvious questions that's all it takes
care about what other people are saying
watch the world around you take an
interest in something beyond yourself
and when he does that they don't like it
watch this exchange with dr robert
malone who's one of the inventors of
mrna technology
the how question of a third of the
population basically being hypnotized
and totally wrapped up in whatever tony
fauci in the mainstream media feeds them
whatever cnn tells them is true the
answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has
free-floating anxiety in a sense that
things don't make sense
we can't understand it
and then their attention gets focused by
a leader or series of events on one
small point just like hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
that was the interview that pushed cnn
completely over the edge not because it
was false but because it was entirely
credible
hypnotizing the public that's our job
they said
mass formation psychosis
yeah that's us
so of course they immediately set about
encouraging the tech platforms to ban
that interview dr malone again one of
the inventors of mrna technology being
used in over a billion doses
of
vaccine currently in people's bodies
that's the man who was talking
credible yeah no one more credible than
that and that's exactly why they hated
it and it's exactly why they said you
couldn't hear it
now that same month was this past
december rogan spoke to a doctor called
peter mccullough about ivermectin watch
this
sanjay gupta and the cnn correspondent
yeah
there was no fair balance there he
paired it a talking point that our head
of the national allergy and immunology
branch parroted
they said that there was no data for
ivermectin
they said it was a horse dewormer
now either they knew or they should have
known the 63 supportive studies and of
the over 30 randomized trials
so those are facts and if you think
they're wrong tell us how they're wrong
but why shouldn't people hear that why
shouldn't they be allowed to well
because dr peter mccullough who
certainly has the credentials to do it
criticized the people in charge he
mocked cnn for ignoring dozens of
clinical trials making fun of a drug
that could have helped a lot of people
possibly saved lives what do you think
of that well that's immoral of course
but notice what joe rogan didn't do in
the face of that information he didn't
call for cnn to be censored because they
spread disinformation he didn't say we
got to pull cnn off the air they're
killing people
because he's not for censorship you know
who's for censorship weak people are for
censorship i can't handle what you're
throwing at me shut up or else that's
exactly what they're saying strong
people don't behave that way only the
weak
everybody knows that they can smell it
and the reason joe rogan's successful
because he's not weak
that's the truth hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else